citizens of the reject Nation it is John
it is Tara Erickson and we are back for
another first time movie watch yeah this
time we're watching The Punisher that's
right 2004's Marvel film not John
Bernthal not Ray Stevenson not Dolph
Lundgren or whoever else it's Thomas the
Jane in the title role are you excited
Tara are you ready to get violent
that's right guys before we get to it
leave a like on the video uh comment
below with your favorite way to punish
people hit the Subscribe button and the
notif oh wait wait yeah
hit that subscribe button and when you
do
bring that back
that's right people ring the bell for
the real rejects ring the bell for Tara
Erickson also check out La eats drinks
terror's online food Excursion and
before we get into this we got a panel
coming up at San Diego comic books
convention Saturday Greg Coy and I are
coming to Comic-Con sdcc 2023 we got a
panel live on Saturday so if you're down
in San Diego be sure to check that out
and uh hey if you want to get the full
experience with us see everything that
doesn't make these reaction highlights
come on over to patreon.com the real
rejects where you can sync up with your
own copy watch The Punisher along with
us and without further Ado I think we're
ready for some punishment
thing
and we got the old Marvel bumper with a
little Punisher sprinkled in hey
hey guys
do this
[Music]
cool opening titles I don't know why
it's giving me like a metal gear Vibe
but
it's got that kind of dramatic heft just
classic cool animation
[Music]
where's my pickup truck let's do this
you need that sticker in the back window
yes about yay size Mr Astros trust is
not gained easily he doesn't like new
faces so tell me why am I looking
flip-flops yeah with a suit Auto Creek
meet my friend Bobby he's helping me
with the finance he's not a cop neither
of those is Liv Schreiber
oh oh
yes
now you're speaking his language
[Music]
under arrest for the importation and
sale of Contraband firearms
whoa damn this is not my deal I don't
even know these guys
[Music]
don't point a gun like that in a
standoff people are just waving guns
around like it's NBD I hope the Punisher
wears flip-flops the rest of the movie
well it is Florida it's hot and sticky
I was waiting for that
happened who's the kid well definitely
not in the plan but we beat the spread
this isn't football
you know sting operations football same
diff or not I mean he looks very fit
he's Robert Saint Howard Saints son uh
oh I can't be good I want to know one
thing only who broken the deal his name
is Otto Krieg and if it's any comfort to
Mr Saint he's dead too well it's not oh
oh we got a Travolta a man who's
responsible for my son's death Must Die
oh I told you to never let him out of
your sight Bobby told me to stay it was
Bobby's idea he wanted to go alone thank
you for that explanation
now someone bring me Caster Troy
more boxes guys
sure the lady Castle
oh
this was a hard one this was the last
one you're out for good
now you guys can just hang at home and
make out
so much making out to catch up on
London's a safe place where we can all
be together no more moving around I
promise someday when you're older will
I'll tell you why we had to move so much
so close to a Tony Stark goatee would
you pay in Howard will know everything
there is to know about Otto Creed within
24 hours
oh
that was a quick cut yep
Puerto Rico
drone shots before there were drone
shots when it was called a helicopter
and the man hanging out of the side of
said helicopter
hey Frank is that that uh Candelaria
people around here call him a witch
doctor lives on that island way off the
point only one damn fool I know crazy
enough to swim over there
oh I bet that's gonna come back let's
get some Voodoo in here I'm very happy
that you're all here I'm very proud that
you're wrong what is his name and that I
love you
salute
I lost so much time with both of you and
I'm really sorry hey hey hey I married
you I knew what I was doing
and I do it again oh
sweet
you and I
we're not lucky we are blessed yes we
are I ship them every couple
his name's Frank Castle
oh no she's got the bureau's London desk
no
connections dang it he's leaving for
England next week and he's at a family
reunion in Puerto Rico I think you
should be there
back and tell Olivia how he died oh boy
wait
what kill them too this whole family oh
yeah okay girl every generation you can
get your hands on Kill Them All were
selling T-shirts in town one of them was
really scary the guy in the shop said it
Wards off evil spirits it's really
intense oh goodness oh no oh no
yes
love it yes uh Wards off bad spirits I
also bought you this Iron Maiden album
is this all their family I guess kill a
lot of people
oh boy oh my God this does feel like a
movie at an earlier time I know we're in
2004 but something feels like yeah like
older sensibility yeah yeah makes me
wonder who directed this like if they
got maybe like an international action
director to come over or something
oh no oh
jeez geez why you go for the old lady
first the grandma start with Mom okay
all right oh man
oh
my gosh oh
jeez
dive over the mini bar oh I'm gonna blow
up some propane tanks
Frank Castle plays games nice he's a
gamer cool
he killed Michael Myers yeah it
definitely it was like they didn't try
to hide that that was a full-on dummy
okay
oh dang it no damn you umbrella guy what
what
yes
good job dad like a true Castle
classic trip action
it's a good stunt
it's like felt like a real yes and she
has a boat too nice
come out oh hey dude
totally just Mission Impossible dead
okay so he cut his cheek all right he's
gonna bleed out over the next several
days
whoa whoa whoa that was cool
awesome
[Music]
oh my goodness these stunts are pretty
wild that is an amazing stunt like what
they're also taking these cars
suspensions to the absolute limit yeah
oh
oh don't you know it yep
[Music]
oh my god oh my God this is terrible
quite tragic yeah
[Music]
come on Grandpa's boat hurry hurry hurry
oh my goodness come on honey oh geez no
no just drum in the water jump in the
water jump in the water
oh my gosh
I just got pancakes oh my gosh no way I
did not think
oh
my gosh where did the truck go oh yeah
where is it is it what the what where's
the car
it's right there
is it hiding no that's a boat what what
did I do like he got there that late the
car could already what back up and take
off I guess no
oh it's down there very long dock okay a
lot of places to hide on this wide open
dock now we must punish oh yeah
hey what's the paint man
Wowie
[Music]
knew this was coming Pete
oh
okay mother and father send the regards
this time they're not blanks
[Music]
it's an interesting cut
agua in the agua
[Music]
whoa nice
laughs
that's awesome that's a real explosion
this movie is very tangible
ouch God all the blood he must have lost
in there it's like The Little Mermaid
but the horror version he's with a man
the little gun maid
oh the guy that owns a fuel place is he
gonna save him yeah man
bring me some thingama bobbers
they crowd tonight Mr sink you look
beautiful little prick
holy Gangland style I hope they
call him Francis for the rest of the
movie it's like that the punisher's name
is Francis
okay now he enjoys being a cook
guys
it's right there yeah what what what's
going on here come on man is this how
you you went out of her
girl's best friend
oh dang okay oh yeah all right here we
go hey girl hey a little post-mortar uh
post-murder post murder uh copulation
we call it yeah
yeah Sam how long has it been a few
weeks at least a month or two this beard
grows that fast no like three months
right
okay
all right pack up your little Arsenal it
is funny that the cops would come and
board it up but leave the guns I know
we'll just leave that there
uh is that the shirt that would be the
shirt
oh yeah you're wearing that now
now it's badass enough yeah
go with God God's gonna sit this one out
God's Gonna via Khan himself yeah I got
a shirt that's good karma and Wards off
stuff I don't need God
and is there a subtle implication that
you know Voodoo helped preserve his life
after being filled with holes
let's go whisking guns Gear Up montage
cool oh my gosh cool cool cool cool it's
like home alone with the grown-up
version yeah
this makes you want Italian food
Ben Foster you
you are is he talking to himself to your
mother and I this is a mirror I can't
wait
did he have a headset on and I didn't
see it
ah great guy in the chair
Rebecca Romaine what do you think he
does
he's an artist wow my neighbor is an
artist so what do you think he's doing
he's doing art stay away from your
Castle I have friends here let's
talk about your friends make your own
friends body I'm not saying no you can't
have any of my friends
clever
[Music]
he's killing someone and we're next
exactly
alt Universe Sean Annette over here any
discussion of how it changed business
involves two cubes Toro Brothers they
control all the prostitution of gambling
wowie whoa they give their dirty money
to Howard Saint transports it in
cigarette boats to his Banks and Grand
Cayman Washington oh my gosh the guy who
does Impressions it's
yeah he's my friend I didn't know he's
in this movie dude he's gonna be
punishing people
You're Gonna Want to Say Howard Saints
Lackey for the rest of your life I hate
the Saints tell me about them what they
do where when why how he has first tea
time five days a week at Tampa Springs
Hawaii Libya every Thursday she works
out gets her nails done and goes to the
movies she only works out on Thursday
one day a week let's not forget Johnny
Boy the son you didn't kill what a putz
whoa Clinton's glass yeah with our 20
years the family conciliary lawyer CPA
and a sadist
cancellieri
he's gonna kiss that girl yeah I thought
they were gonna make out yeah oh he's
just threatening him okay are they gonna
make out oh my God yes
we saw it
yeah baby I mean I want that guy to die
and all but also I'm happy he's he's
yeah it's true
Oh I thought he'd be dragging it
what's it on top of the car
those pipe things hilarious
oh I think I might oh
nice dude that's awesome that's awesome
poor guy although I guess anyone who
works at Saint Industries is a bad
person yeah they're all bad it's part of
the hiring process they make very
interesting bad guy yeah yeah all their
employees for Peak irony
whoa yes
get up feel the money okay cool
nice
the window
oh golly
we gotta get some money nice
[Music]
happiest day of my life
no good business nice murder to say pay
you for each one or does he get a group
rate discount
he gets him in bulk from Costco I like
to purchase six orders of murder
fastest draw on the East Coast but how
can we make him suffer if we can't find
him he's Darius he misses his family and
he wants to die he's asking for help so
let's help him
we'd be doing him a service a kindness
we want our money back and we want
protection on the next shipment do you
guarantee our money this time everything
I've got
can't tell if they're confident in that
answer or not
whoa
[Music]
you should leave right now shut your
face you lard ass
that's mean body shame my dude I'm gonna
call it cops damn
hey get out yeah
nice
get out
yeah cool knives
I was gonna say whack him with it love
it I'm Joan Dave's the one with all the
um the metal they're called piercings
we're really
really sucks why did you say that name
all right she just got done with the
workout now she's back in her dress and
she's going to a movie we know it's a
Thursday man buenos dias Pablo Film
Festival
is that an exploding fire hydrant all
right or is he just gonna get her a
ticket
she left her purse in the car yes
carrying those around in the case aren't
those worth millions what is she doing
quitting glass
why do you work for a homophobe man yeah
shame shame I guess there's got to be a
lot more tolerant crime syndicates out
there not with the Saints
oh it's just so nobody else would park
there okay all right smart
I know my Mr glasses as some pulling
into the Wyndham Hotel a couple hours
ago strategically placed Mickey yeah I
was just telling
where you been Clinton
without by the pool well Mickey said
that he saw you at the window Mickey
should have his eyes checked a lot of
guys around with this beard
morning sir sit down where you like
spin us an outlaw yarn on that their
guitar
I feel like it's not a guitar what else
could fit in a guitar case Tara so my
case I can hear what you're thinking
oh you doubt sin fear
you may come back someday
[Music]
it's a famous musician he's got such
like Johnny Cash Vibes you like that
song
singing at your funeral
I mean why does Harry heck have a
problem
it's James
did he just like crush his thumb under
something or yeah it's been green and
then now it looks okay oh
whoa shazbot
it just fixed this up
come on oh damn it Desperado all right
[Applause]
whoa that's awesome nice yeah good stunt
these cars
[Applause]
oh no the car dude it was so fresh and
so clean
you are one dumb son of a
we're gonna have to a gunfight
yeah
whoa whoa
oh awesome spring loaded nice good thing
Harry heck has a nice vehicle oh yeah
and sustained minimal damage
[Music]
whatever could this be
nicely done cool oh it's not about money
it's about sending a message
yeah nice avenging Spirit shipment of
cash
that's what happens
and I get this why because
scare me there's no insurance in this
business you know that dang and Mike if
you don't like it just remember one
thing
I've got more guns than you do all right
let's see them we don't have more guns
it's my duty it's hard duty to make
castle dead I don't care what it takes
what it costs call the Russian oh yeah
Mr Cash we need your help right now
because
the guy who's after Joan is in her
apartment
right now
we want you to have dinner with us huh
oh that's sweet sorry I tricked you
hey
you ain't seen food in a while huh
it's dessert
come on
I need your help
uh oh it's a meat cute a setup
good ones good memories can save your
life
come on not yet I'm not what you're
looking for
damn it go to him
I don't think it's them
[Music]
found Waldo yep
whoa if Waldo was a Dolph Lundgren
character
[Music]
yes dude cool
foreign
yeah nice
I love the Trope that being that buff
just just doesn't matter if you get
stabbed
oh no
[Music]
oh geez
yes yeah all right
oh
friendship Don't Wanna Die Punk monkey
wrench
yes
[Music]
whoa
no oh my gosh get it go yeah
hahaha
nice pose
yes
yes oh right through the wall
oh my God this fight
whoa
how does this building work oh they
thought they were neighbors but now are
they down the holler across the way or
or is both possible around
good
yes oh no
dang it
well that sucks oh my goodness he is
getting slams
come on help him yeah
hot pasta hot pasta on his head yeah
Bernie's face off
[Music]
oh God that looks bad hey you're not
gonna like this guy when he's angry
wow I love how much they're selling the
destruction these guys are gonna have to
move out Mr Castle
Frank
he's not he's not
he needs a doctor you need a doctor no
hospital no please that's what you want
to hear
I like it sure looks like you know what
you're doing Jones
not much
where's Castle
it's not here
really
are you sure
what are you doing with all this stuff
what is that
sure things do you like that
I heard a little bit
there's a special one noon no wow please
don't I was worried about this
yep
God damn it ah guys coming no I don't
want it yeah second I saw him I was like
they're gonna do something with these
piercings
I hate it
doesn't have to be this way
look like you know about pain
[Music]
I opened up the lens on that stuff if
when he shows up
kill him you have to know by now that
that is not enough right just to be like
hey they have not learned their no one's
had been on the program of killing this
you should kill him I got a bright idea
why don't you kill this guy
wow all of them all of them I I figured
it must be but yeah say a big old thank
you to Dave yeah yeah I mean like he did
not need to keep his mouth shut right
yeah he kind of has only known you for a
couple seconds for real
yeah go for that let's do
it let's do yank that thing off
[Music]
yeah buddy
nice you don't know me anything
bro you're nothing but trouble why are
you ready to die for me
either one of us
oh
your family oh
you kill them all what makes you any
different from
some to lose
woof the boot camp Sergeant made us
recite It Like a Prayer
sick this pocon Parabellum if you want
peace
prepare for war
sir
Joan or Joan
you listen to me you
said
let's do a glass
just come out it'll be easier yeah it's
the mid-2000s you'll be okay-ish okay
ish yeah I was detailing Mrs Saints card
I found this ticket where was it
the
ticket September
5th last Thursday that was when your
buddy was there
oh they probably set it up to put the
wife's clothes in there huh
oh the earring
nice subtle touch in the bed good long
game damn all right car
ticket the hydrants earrings now he's
just taken care of by the boss
what are you doing here you know Jim
Bowie the colonel the man who died in
the Alamo had a knife named after him
he's a gambler Bowie knife I'm not
following this I'm choosing you
oh boy
My Life True if you're gonna do it next
time the Windham
what you talking about
oh nice body check it's in a funny hour
oh Wowie
what do you think I'm an idiot
have you lost your mind ah
oh my brother I gave you everything
tonight for nothing you might live who
is she tell you
just tell him tell him you are gay
oh man damn that's gonna wreck you for a
long time when those pictures come out
with him and his boyfriend dude yeah
just lost your right hand for nothing he
went to the movies last Thursday eight
o'clock
yes then at nine o'clock he called him
from your car there's an explanation oh
I know
my best friend that would be a
little hard to accomplish Howard
oh she knows
I was gay
you just talked to me
all right first time I saw you was only
three bucks for me now it's just for
she'll fit right in uh dude
so evil come on guys you gotta just
throw the pictures his way because she
didn't really do anything she kind of
was like killed the whole family though
I mean she did order the holes yeah I
found that in quinton's bed does that
make enough sense for you huh
oh
God me neither ew oh
wow
yeah okay that's done with
jeez a lot of people getting hit by
moving vehicles in this no no don't grab
the track ah you could have
I don't know the logistics of hiding
under a train but I feel like she could
have she could have maybe done it if she
just would have turned perpendicular I
mean parallel
fifty thousand a piece and 50 000 more
to the man who kills him if you accept
this money
you're in till it's over
yeah a little bit of John Wick Vibes
sure
the clock is ticking yeah Frank Castle
is excommunicado
Extreme situations
the law is inadequate in order to shame
its inadequacy
it is necessary to act outside the law
whoa this is not vengeance
revenge is not a valid motive it's an
emotional response
true that not Vengeance Justice
punishment oh sure yeah
[Music]
this is it for a building where is he
it's under all the cars
okay I was like that's a lot of cars
ah not bad nice
hey Eddie more champagne on the double
ride the dumb waiter
yes
cool
he's in the bucket
[Music]
all right
cooking fools
ouch
dang
wow
oh no get him
that was a very real response
wow
that's awesome
that was cool God they really went to
town on that particular guy
Come On Son
you won't get to it in time buddy reads
a little harder
his personal mine weighs eight pounds
stretched arm
oh geez oh
my no workout
sure nice punishment I hope we come back
after the credits and his arm is like a
huge boss
took everything for me
you killed my son
my son
was in a place he wasn't supposed to be
foreign
Showdown
yeah where'd you kill your best friend
full circle nice damn
made you kill your wife
oh that's painful oh my God
wow and now I'm gonna drag you all over
town oh wow
[Music]
oh no
oh man
[Music]
wow
oh cool
oh look it's Mr Myers again oh we didn't
get a close-up no stunt double no
I feel like we should be playing that
that classical oh
I was taking a lot of planning oh my God
it's been sitting there sketching out
like what which color stories do I need
to bomb my control the spread of the
Flames oh so I don't get the teeth right
this is so good it's like when Batman
did that whole like big flame bat Dark
Knight Rises
Miss Joan
oh
maybe you want to live after all yeah
remember your new family you're right
good memories can save your life when
Dave gets out of the hospital check the
cupboard I left something you're leaving
I have work to do read your newspaper
every day you'll understand
oh geez wow which section the punishing
one obituaries
nice
now you guys can fix that dump up yeah
oh
dude all right you guys never have to
work again question is is he gonna get
those piercings replaced eventually or
just let it of course he will it's part
of his personality that's true
how much is it
yeah
[Music]
yes
uno dos tres one for ichia very cool
good for them
I'm gonna miss those guys these sunsets
I can't yeah beautiful and you know they
had to shoot them for real yeah
those who do evil to others The Killers
psychos sadists you'll come to know me
well ah Frank Castle is dead call me
Punisher
God keep that crane steady
sorry it's what this music is made that
was good
oh my goodness Tara Erickson we finally
saw the Punisher yeah wow wow wow wow
that was so much fun I can't that was a
blast which yeah would you think oh it's
great I loved it like I need to go and
buy a Punisher t-shirt right now because
I have a new I have a new found just
like yes you're gonna be rocking the
punishment oh yeah Kevin feige got a
credit man he was already working on
this stuff way back in the DIA
this was fun
yeah it was fun I mean like it's weird
you know knowing the Punisher as a
character and and seeing you know at
least you know being familiar with the
show and stuff like that you have an
idea of of what the oh Conrad Hall shot
this nice uh you have an idea of of the
sort of movie you're getting into and
this has that but it wasn't exactly what
I was expecting exactly like it's
certainly an action movie there's a lot
of Carnage and and violence and stunts
and a body count but it's not like as
extreme and like just middle the whole
time as as you would maybe expect you
know like the John Bernthal Punisher is
like oh I love that show it's great and
it's like it's harsh and and like
yeah there's a different quality to like
who Frank Castle is here and it feels
kind of like indicative of yeah an
earlier you know period of this kind of
movie and these Comics adaptation to the
screen and uh it's been interesting
because uh what does it mean Roxy have
been watching the Blade movies which
started in the late 90s and go through
the 2000s and then this is like the
early 2000s and like watching this this
has definitely like a
it feels yeah like we were talking about
it has that kind of like 90s sort of
breathability where like
again I don't I don't know like what the
the most definitive version of the
origin is but this felt kind of like the
right especially for the moment in time
balance between yes this is an action
movie it's got all a lot of the comic
book you know uh aspects and motifs and
stuff like that but like at the start of
the movie I was like you know oh this is
like this is starting out like
it feels like I'm watching face off or
something like that where it's like you
have this sort of steady build of the
circumstances
like I don't know I guess I I initially
had expected the kind of movie where you
would start out on some kind of Massacre
of his family and that's like the
prologue right and then the rest of it
is like yeah this really harsh like
grimy gritty thing which you know might
come you know in later movies or like
war zone or you know but uh but yeah
this was this was a neat like Time
Capsule because of that because it has I
guess what I'm trying to say is like it
has all that punisher-ness but not
exactly yeah as like roided out of an
experience as you might expect yeah they
took their time more at the top with
like the family setting it up that it
was like oh let's just see him in his
like five language setup like setting
these guys up right using all of his
skills that was John Pinette of course
uh uh bimbo or whatever his name was
like he's so freaking funny oh my God
I've seen his stand up a million times I
was trying to place him he's great um
but yes continue sorry uh no it's all
good I mean he's he's great uh
what was I saying oh yeah I was just
saying that they have a more of the
setup at the top which yeah it's it's
like oh okay we get to see him with his
skill set and setting up these people
and then cut to the family and seeing
like the origin of the T-shirt yes uh
was is pretty awesome that it comes from
like his son so it has this sentiment
attached to it yeah
um is that a comic comment below is that
a comic accurate detail yeah I I mean I
would love to know I'm like unless they
just add that in the only one thing that
I thought was really weird in this movie
is that when they go they put him and
her down below in the when they're uh
interrogating Dave yeah and she's
covering his mouth I'm like well why he
wouldn't know how to be quiet like right
like he's making too much noise
occasionally going
uh that's the only thing unless you
would be like fighting her like I'm
gonna go up I I would understand the
sentiment of him saying I'm gonna go up
and I'm gonna freaking kill him like
don't touch Dave don't touch my friends
yeah that was the only one weird thing
and she kept covering his mouth that he
looked passed out
um any other than that I love the
freaking movie but you guys know me I
always point out the weird things I'm
like this one weird thing I don't know
it's in my head hey other than that he's
self-terror the car stunts were freaking
amazing I love the low angle catching
every car go over like a hump or flying
in the air there was obviously a style
to it where you can catch more of the
height from a lower angle with the cars
and I thought that was dope yeah the one
thing that the Michael Myers
masks were awesome but that one was a
little obvious where I'm a little I
don't know I'm like oh couldn't they
just have thrown like a couple thou at
it to be like make that not look like
that yeah
slightly frequently so you can't see the
the mask the mask yeah it's either yeah
it's either a dummy or an actor like
with yeah protective mask or something I
think it's a dummy It's gotta be right I
mean that was the only other thing but
the stunts in this were awesome they
were like they were they really again I
guess that's it it's like you know it's
not it's definitely got a lot of action
it's definitely got a lot of deaths and
stuff like that and a lot of you know
like gratifying Revenge not Vengeance
punishments punishments um but yeah it's
like when there are action scenes going
down they are like so there's just like
so much destruction and and yeah like in
the car chases they're really like
visceral and the way they're capturing
them you just feel the weight and the
kind of I don't know like how much
damage these vehicles must be taking on
and then all the physical stunts do too
like all those fights and especially
like you know the more you're like
wrecking a room like when they're in uh
his place and that big wall though guys
yeah beat the crap out of him and
throwing them through walls and and
through railings and and like there's so
many physical elements that get
destroyed throughout all this like
really sells the studs and you're like
yeah this all this just looks painful
yeah and even though it's not
necessarily the kind of movie poised to
give you like a million money shots like
they do have a good amount of like
distinct kills and uh and yeah they
build the stakes of like you know I
don't know if this uh Saint character is
necessarily like you know a prominent
comic book villain for The Punisher he's
not like jigsaw necessarily where he's
like big and outlandish but you know
like he he is certainly hateable and I
loved watching Frank like really like in
a long game sort of way dismantle and
ultimately destroy his entire higher
operation and yeah like you know on the
heels of having his family Massacre then
he makes him do it by his own hand
essentially is is super smart yeah it's
like personal and harsh and skin nasty I
was so glad when those pictures came
back I was like yeah he's gonna regret
that so hard and then they did at the
very end with the earring I was like oh
that's awesome well that too because
because the thing is you know again with
takes on The Punisher and I haven't seen
every Take On The Punisher but uh you
know I think you you imagine that it's
gonna lead with physicality with big
guns with Carnage but I liked here that
certainly while he's physically capable
he's also like smart and a tactician and
he's good at like sizing up who he's
going up against and using all that
stuff against them and using their own
hubris and all that stuff to ultimately
really seal their downfall and playing
yeah their own deceits against each
other like I love that at first you're
like what's this thing with the fire
hydrants and the car
and pretty soon you're like wow oh yeah
he is so smart save that spot spin this
lie yeah yeah and then watch it come
back later and uh yeah like the prologue
of the movie I was I was like are we
watching the right film right now
because I'm not as familiar with the
idea that he's like you know an
undercover FBI guy doing this stuff but
it was fun to see like yeah Thomas Jane
like in a totally different mode playing
this like I don't know I can remember
he's like Russian or German or whatever
um you know like it starts out
more like an earlier movie adaptation
too where you feel like okay we've kind
of taken it and made it like I feel like
nowadays you get like a John Bernthal
who looks like freaking huge and like he
could you know beat the out of
anybody and like Thomas Jane he's fit
certainly he's muscular in this you
believe everything he's doing but he's
not like so giant and yeah he's not like
built like some machines so it's like
even though there are aspects of this
where I'm like I wonder how like you
know people would view this in terms of
like being a definitive Punisher or not
but I thought this really nicely split
the difference between being like you
know a film of its time but also very
much translating so much of the source
material of the Punisher you mean yeah
exactly like it doesn't necessarily feel
like you know it's not a one-to-one to
what they do with like the the John
Bernthal show or anything like that but
uh but yeah I don't know it felt like it
breathed and moved and had scenes like
an actual movie from this time uh and so
yeah it I'm just fascinated by that
because we have so many of these kinds
of movies and adaptations now and there
are you know stylistic earmarks that can
feel very sort of requisite or alike in
the current days sort of superhero movie
complex but uh I don't know going back
to these little time capsules is great
because I don't know yeah again this
this does you got John Travolta in here
and like yeah
kept reminding me in little ways sort of
of a movie like face off it's not quite
as long as that but you know it's that
same thing of like this this conflict
based on a very personal sort of death
or Massacre and then yeah watching these
two guys sort of cat and mouse each
other until it comes to this final
showdown and uh yeah I thought it was
nicely handled like it was
is it interesting it was like it wasn't
exactly what I expected but it was like
the right amount of what I expected yeah
and like the the one part that I think
they could have done a little bit more
of because I'm like the stunts in this
are so awesome that I'm like come on the
wife and the son you have a car behind
you and there's water jump off the sides
and have the cars like hit them and have
like the body fall I don't know do some
cool stunt thing I know that they
probably in their head they wanted a
shot where he's holding them because it
makes it for like engaging for the
audience but I always think like comic
panel I just want I always want it to be
like make the every single person in
this like smart that they know how to
like outskirt death a little bit like we
all would
um I just was like oh that would be that
would make him extra mad if like the
wife was like in half over the edge
that's bad that's just me and my brain
going somewhere because I'm like don't
you think they would have thought just
jump in the water anyway
um the next my favorite favorite shot
was when knife goes through that guy's
mouth and he's just like
that guy that's so awesome uh he must be
like a pro I recognize him I feel like
that I've seen him in movies as maybe
just as stunts but maybe that's why they
spent time on him because you're like
they spent time on that guy yeah he got
the special treatment in terms of like
horror he gets he got the good shot he
gets the the cheek slice the mi2 cheek
slice early on and then he gets like all
of the knives later yeah yeah and a
close-up shot of his face yeah and the
knife goes through which is really
lovely in my opinion sure oh my gosh and
the the pull-up of the crane in the shot
over the head of the cars with the
Punisher like in Flames come on man
that's so comic book and like uh awesome
and that's and it's like the right
amount of cheese that's the thing is
like I feel like a little corny but
great yeah yeah yeah and it works again
for like for 2005 for the kind of movie
we're going with and for the the fact
that like these movies too have just a
different sense of humor and I feel like
that is you know a bit humorous in its
height you know he had to clearly have
mapped out this you know fire skull but
yeah it's like it's just the right pitch
and it makes it really fun and this
movie I think manages to nicely occupy a
space where yeah it is kind of harsh and
there is like some bleakness to it but
it's not like too dark to where it's not
fun in a way it is that kind of like
more exploitation movie brand of fun
because like you know Dave and his name
bimbo and Joan like all three of them
super charming and I really like them
and and they entered the plot in a very
sort of gradual and and just believable
way like I thought this was kind of
gracefully paced in a lot of Senses
minus maybe a couple like harsh Cuts
here or there yeah that there was only
one harsh cut which I everything else
was cut really nicely especially when
they go up to when he goes up through
the dumb waiter and there's like the
champagne cut to like guy blood
champagne popping off it felt that that
cutting felt like really modern there
was one at the very beginning that I was
just like how did nobody realize like
this is a harsh cut everything else I
thought was was awesome but I thought
that the three of them added heart to
the movie yeah in in a way that you you
didn't really see coming you just
thought maybe the heart exists over here
and there's there's three buddies that
look out the Punisher but then when it
all comes together and they invite him
to to dinner and Dave is like well the
reason I didn't speak up because we're
all thinking that like bro you met this
guy 20 minutes ago kind of like why are
you gonna have your face torn up for him
but the the sentiment is is they live by
if your family that's just how we roll
and they of course Very Much deserve
however much money they got in those
even though he has not known them for
long these are the type of people that
deserve uh the rewards that come with
standing by a neighbor yeah which I
really liked that they got that reward
yeah and I believe that that Bond
happening of like even though yeah we
don't know each other super well there's
something about this ragtag group like
they all just felt like they kind of
congealed because they wound up at the
same building and sort of bonded just
despite all the circumstances and so I
thought that nicely kind of allowed them
to have the will they won't they with
him and Joan and then It ultimately
doesn't turn into anything but that
feels appropriate and so uh yeah just
like a lot of nice little flourishes and
things like that a lot of great
character actors across this uh uh the
guy who played glass especially the guy
who played Mickey I've seen them in a
few other things as well and uh and and
like yeah that too like him doing the
whole blowtorch popsicle oh yeah you
forgot about that like that was such a
great little gag so great yeah yeah all
of it I enjoyed this quite a bit I'm
curious to hear what people's responses
are because yeah I feel like in the
Modern Age you expect uh it's just
something like more kind of thrasher
punishing and thrashy and balls to the
walls and just car Carnage on Carnage
and this is definitely an action movie
but it's not like overwhelming you I
feel like it knows well enough and it's
from a time where it's like yeah let's
let's breathe this out let's build some
steaks let's Mount some things so that
when stuff really starts to pop off you
feel it and you want that catharsis of
the punishment yeah yeah yeah yeah well
you got any extra stray thoughts before
we get out of here I had a blast man no
man this is good old times and I can't
wait to get my Punisher t-shirt even
though John Burns out like a show I
loved that show I was like oh I'm in it
but like why didn't I get a t-shirt then
dude you're not a you're a fake fan Tara
I know man well now I know because I was
like well I hadn't watched this one so
like I wasn't about to buy a t-shirt
when I knew there were other Punisher
things out there that I have not watched
so not really am I a fake fan I'm a
smart fan right I'm not trying to no I'm
not trying to walk around the T-shirt
being like I watched the show but I
didn't watch that movie from 2004 so
like I
just leave those out of it because I
want the T-shirt now and I don't want to
have to say that I've got three other
movies I gotta get to before I can wear
the T-shirt the next time you see Tara
Erickson she will be in a Punisher team
three of them
absolutely all at once well guys leave
us your thoughts on The Punisher leave a
like on the video tell us what you are
interested in seeing next and uh and hey
how do you feel about Thomas Jane in the
role I guess I guess before we get out
of here we should at least touch on it I
liked him a lot yeah yeah yeah like he's
uh I thought his he did the transition
really well because you believe him as
like you know happy family reunion guy
ex-military but not like 2x military to
the point where you're like
this guy is is just that always you know
yeah and then when it transitions into
him you know really having his life torn
down like I almost had that sort of
robocop-esque kind of tragedy where it's
like oh man they're just going like so
hard on this guy and his whole family
and they're like shooting him up and
yeah I thought he like did a really nice
job of of anchoring this I feel like
people don't bring up his portrayal as
much and certainly John Bernthal kind of
towers above everything now but I
thought he did a really nice job with
this and and yeah like I feel like he's
a bit like of an understated kind of
choice but I really liked his presence
here and and that short he did it was
this short called laundry day
um they got some pretty yeah there was a
period of time where uh I think his name
is Artie Shankar he was like producing a
bunch of like really Pro ass fan films
fan shorts and uh Thomas Jane came back
for that so I'm glad that he at least
got the respect uh from that nice yeah
yeah I thought he was awesome and I was
like oh I need to watch a TV show that
he's in because now I see his face and
I'm like he's a lead in a TV show right
now and I don't know what the TV show is
but I gotta watch it they're like by the
beach and he has guns yeah pretty sure
and there's like another lady he's gonna
lead with you guys can leave it in the
comments and yell at me where he belongs
on the beach with guns and a lady
exactly because yeah he's one of those
actors too where I feel like there was a
moment where it seems like oh man this
guy's gonna star on a bunch of stuff and
then he yeah and then he didn't continue
that but he's like in in he still
continuously has worked yeah and he'll
these days he keeps showing up in places
where I'm like oh Thomas James in
it and he's always really every time I
see him I'm always like he leaves an
impression he's really good he's very
good at what he does guys leave us your
thoughts on The Punisher leave us a
comment with your wishes leave a like on
the video and hey last but not least
before we get out of here let's do a
page
Chris Wham off Chris listen buddy I know
we often talk about how good of a guy
Chris is like one of the best people
really he's out here always looking out
for folks a participant in his community
Chris is an altruistic caring person all
right I mean I'm just gonna take John's
word for it but I'm not gonna say that I
truly believe it because I haven't met
you yet Chris okay that's the thing
though is is you don't know where the
line is with Chris you know he could
become the Punisher if pushed far enough
wow and uh I don't I mean I don't wish
that upon you but at the same time I'm
like what would it be like if pretty
cool
because I don't think yeah just knowing
who you're what your moral compass is
like I don't think you would take it out
on everybody I feel like the people who
need to be taken out he takes out that's
what Chris does that's what Chris does
yeah he knows he knows
good guy you stay good guy stays bad guy
goes yeah so even at the brink of
nihilistic despair I feel like you would
still have a good grip on the moral
compass and uh Hey if you showed up and
you were like you know it's time to
accept your punishment I'll probably be
like yeah you know I trust your judgment
Chris I probably have done some heinous
things so uh you know I I just do what
you got to do and make it for me I'd be
like and it's time for you to accept
yours no so then it would be a Face-Off
between me and you Chris it could be his
arch nemesis villain guys it's time for
a lady Punisher lady Punisher Punisher
put me in it man punish watch my reels
they're on YouTube all right I'm telling
you that that genre of film that fits
perfect for me it's so bad Miss Punisher
put me in it come on now Chris if
there's a Miss Punisher that comes out
and they don't let me audition I'm gonna
write that comic so that Tara has a star
vehicle thank you so much that's how you
avoid this this life language but anyway
we love you buddy stay pledged and uh
we'll catch you next month thank you for
all your support and for being a good
human a bright light and a shining
example to us all
much love buddy we did it